so first things first last week I
overrun on my five-minute rule and as
this is a no fight area inspired video
that means that I must do some formal
punishment on camera so to get that out
of the way put suggestions for
punishments in the comments below in
your video Jamie you asked me the
question well it's been my favorite part
of the university experience I have to
think quite hard about that because
there's an awful lot of things who have
the university experience that I really
love and I think my favorite thing about
the whole thing is the autonomy that you
get the freedom it's simple things like
being able to go out for a run whenever
you want or be able to eat wherever food
you want going out with your friends
whenever like the fact that you are
completely free in this amazing safety
only think of a question for you I'll
come back to that one later in the video
so it's not be able to tell I'm hanging
a bit but I'm absolutely exhausted
because this week's been so busy with
work but also because last night I went
to this Ranger which is new term for me
apparently it's an American basically an
American frat party there's a huge
numbers of visiting students in Oxford
and some Peters is loads of American
visiting students and they threw this
huge epic party last night probably the
best one I hope into my time at uni I
played beer pong for the first time in
my life but as a consequence didn't get
all of that much sleep so what we've
been doing over the past couple weeks is
the standard stuff problem-sets classes
lectures but I've also had this master's
project in the background which is now
starting to round up and intensity so my
Master's project is in atmospheric
physics department and in particular I'm
looking at stochastic models of the
atmosphere so there's a thing called a
air interim which is essentially huge
data set of the entire planets wind and
temperature at different heights and at
different latitudes and altitudes what I
am doing is saying ok let's look at a
particular point let's pretend that we
could model this incredibly complicated
system by a simple equation and if it
was given by a simple equation which to
gonna import these it is a stochastic
equation and that involves a random
number
generator in there somewhere if it was
being governed by that equation what
parameters would you have to plug in to
that equation in order to make it work
and you do some very nifty analysis
involving the autocorrelation function
of the dataset which allows you to
determine firstly whether you can
represent it you can represent the data
set with this simple model and if so
what parameters you want and that works
pretty well for one point but what we
want to do is do more than one point
trying to see how many points we can
Street together using this really really
simple stochastic model to represent
this the system and see what points that
just breaks down and further that's the
whole notion whether it's just Oh
somewhere in the region of micronesia
and we just don't know because nobody's
tried it before
so for this week's Oxford's specific
thing I'm not traveling very far in fact
I'm staying right here I'm gonna be
taking you to the building world of
Oxford student so out of those two
student newspapers that are published
weekly you've got the cello and the
Oxford student great if you want to go
into media in fact a really good friend
of mine from sand Peters went on from
being the editor the opportunity now
working at Sky News what I love about
the other the press in Oxford is how
varied is because you know you have more
serious stuff like for instance you
thought the local political news that
the university might be involved with
but at the same time you haven't asked
about Jesus colleges tanning team who's
led by their who are led by the
Honorable captain Tam solo and there's
no interesting stuff in here I mean even
just like investigations of a hoax for
so things you weren't necessarily know
there's one here in the cello about for
all prices by college which incidentally
range from to punt when T of
Christchurch did 13 pounds 25 Abellio
definitely not worth it some peers I
should point out six pound 50 very good
value and there's features like you'd
expect in any newspaper elite you've got
reports from clues sports matches you've
got fashion shoots which are terrible
ones you're a physicist I would say that
now for the question for you guys in the
audience this is a an important one
right this is one I read like to hear
back for me what I want you guys to
leave in the comments section is stories
the available Oxford things to do with
interviews maybe to do with the
admissions process to do with life in
general Oxford and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take all of these
questions and I'm gonna go through them
and do a video explaining whether these
things are true or not and if they are
false something a bit closer to the
truth
right I really want to overrun again
because I don't want another punishment
so Jamie your question where is your
favorite place in Oxford and I want
footage of you there explaining why it's
your favorite place Jamie I'll see you
on Thursday